the minnesota twins and boston red sox
mourn the death of dante wright who was
tragically killed on sunday afternoon
in brooklyn center we extend our
sympathies to the family of dante wright
and ask you all to please join the
minnesota twins and boston red sox
with a moment of silence in honor of
dante wright martine perez on the mound
for the red sox
on a frigid day in the twin cities
looking for his first win
boxing hitting lead off for the first
time this year shattered his bat
and down for a hit into the corner how
many for byron
he's got two and he is going to hold up
there with a
first pitch double that's how hot he is
he shattered his bat and he still ends
up at second base
well best way to stay stay warm run the
bases and he goes up there
doesn't waste any time understands who
he's facing knows what he expects to see
and immediately gets involved in this
game he's shaking his fingers a little
bit standing at second base you shake it
off you smile and give the twins a lead
right here base is loaded nobody out
chance for the twins to really open this
game up from the start and
play with the lead and play with a
comfortable lead twins would like to get
polanco's bat going now hitting cleanup
with the bases loaded nobody out
high fly right center field hernandez
drifting back
and on the warning track makes the catch
and the front two runners will tag up so
buxton comes in the twins have the lead
behind him garlic fills third base
well good at bat right here does a good
job of just real simple approach
on a different day this ball is probably
halfway up the scoreboard in right
center field but
because that wind's blowing in cold day
all night carrying
like it does in the middle of summer
either way twins have lead he made sure
he got one run in and then good base
running
by garlic and garver arise off to a
phenomenal start batting almost 360 on
base percentage almost 460
ops over 950 from the stretch and the
one pitch pepper right side he'll have
to hustle to stay out of a double play
and he does reaching in a fielder's
choice another run comes in it's two to
nothing
garver to third base arrives with a run
batted in his sixth of the year
sanders coming off a three-hit game in
baltimore and the lefties two-two
a little roller and arize can't make the
play it actually strikes the bag behind
him
and xander is on with a base hit off the
plate xander just to dribble it down i
don't think arize would have had
even a chance i don't think even
bare-handed that bogey get down the line
too good
so bogey at first base with the infield
single app was ahead but now behind
vasquez
the ground ball to third weekly arise
will step on third for one
throws across the first dugout hasta
deal double play
yep they are going to say the lead
runner is out in the fourth play
so weekly hit to third arise took the
force play at third
to get bogart and thread through across
to first base
and the twins get vasquez as well to
second ever so two outs innovative
office solutions double play
twins by two and now the batter is
renfro
and half with another 22 pitch inning
and the red sox second is history boston
made some noise two on nobody out they
score
nothing and leave a man another run
throw over one struck out in the second
that one launched center field deep
backing up buxton leaping up
can't get it and that ball is gone conor
renfro goes yard against tap and the red
sox are on the board
here in the fifth inning oh right off
the top of the wall
nice effort by buxton out there as he
goes back but hunter renfro has too much
for him gets over his glove and i
believe it went right off the top of the
wall
and out of the ballpark breaking ball
that time looked like a slider 84 miles
an hour
that ball down in the zone and that's
exactly where hunter renfro likes it
a lion drive up the middle of basin into
center for christian arroyo so
the red sox for the first time today put
back-to-back hits together
nice piece of hitting there by a royal
line shot right up the middle
a home run and a base hit off happen
this frame
and there's a shot down the line and
that is going to be a fair ball and go
all the way to the corner
here comes arroyo he is rounding third
and he is going to score and the red
sox have tied it 2-2 bobby dulbeck down
the line to even it up
dave do you remember last at bat and i
said that cora congratulated dolbach on
a fly ball to right field
indeed what does he do this time he goes
back to the opposite field again
but this time on a line so that means
that means a swing
may be coming and sliced it right inside
fair territory
all the way to the wall no problem for
arroyo to score from first base on this
and the red sox have tied the game in
heavy snow
right now it'll be the end of the ball
game for happ
who looked like he was locking things
down at least through the fifth inning
and he'll come out again after four and
two thirds and i think it's cody stachek
coming in
the red sox quiet through four and two
thirds inning string three hits together
score a couple of runs and chase j hat
from the game
the third time through the order begins
with [ __ ] hernandez
yeah that's the tough part is you had
the bottom of the lineup you kind of had
it set up with two outs and
looked like it was just going to be
inning over and nice comfortable lead
and
all of a sudden it flips on you and now
you make a pitching change you got to
deal with the top of the order
another runner in scoring position for
stacia could you really use a strikeout
right here
another 2-2 breaking ball got it
so snatch comes back from 2-0 they do
score two
on three hits they leave one ostidio not
the
ideal first battery he faces snapped his
bat and a roller to bogarts
high throw and he's safe what a slide by
ostadillo
how do you sense that as you're 15
feet from the base you should go into a
slide well he was looking at bogart says
he was running up the line
and he was seeing number one i guess if
he fueled it cleanly
take a look he gets jammed but give him
credit he ran hard out of the box he
looked to see if you feel it and then
your eyes are on the first baseman
you're reading that guy and we saw it
kind of
the last out of the last inning he was
dancing around over at first came off
the base just like dahlbach did there
and made the tag now he's able to kind
of read you see him go he sees it
he's trying to avoid contact i think
maybe as much as anything but
real good athletic play right there
it'll bring up andrew tim simmons three
and one account
three one hammered up the middle oh what
a play arroyo out there on to first for
the double play
arroyo with a tremendous defensive stop
just like that two down while you talk
about positioning i'll tell you what
they had him in the right spot because
that is an absolute bullet by the
pitcher yet he's shading him up the
middle which gave him the ability to
make that play three and two
another big pitch on the way for
sawamura here it is
he struck him out that was 97. what a
pitch from sawamura
bails out bogarts and so does arroyo for
that matter spectacular comeback in the
sixth
christian royal steps into the box for
the socks here in the eighth such a
dramatic turnaround for the red sox
after that opening series which has
become a distant memory
he lashes this one on a line down into
the corner
that carom's up against the fence he's
heading into second
and he walks in with a double to begin
the eighth inning oh he's had a nice day
two for three hitting out on an eight
spot he's had a nice state defensively
at second base big big double hit a lead
off the eighth inning
90 miles an hour i'm not sure exactly
what that was if it was a changeup or
or a fastball but you see it slicing
down in the corner bounces around for a
while
and by the time kepler gets it in red
sox have a man in scoring position here
late in the game
here's bobby dalbeck he drove in a run
with a double back in the fifth inning
red sox would like to see that again
and a live shot and another one to right
field that'll chase in the run
the red sox have the lead bobby dulbeck
with another double to right field
3-2 boston i'm telling you if you don't
think for a second that positive
reinforcement
pays off this is the greatest one of the
greatest examples you can see
the guy makes a good out he comes back
he goes to the opposite field he's got a
3-1
count on him right now what is he trying
to do he's not trying to get too big
right
he just takes it to the opposite field
and drives in the go ahead run that'll
send up rafael devers
at sox 3 minnesota two ninth inning
here's the one-two pitch
high fly ball he turns on this one that
ball
is way way way out of here watch that
one bounce downtown
another home run for rafael devers
that's a home run
in four consecutive games and the sox
lead at four to two
and a huge run in the ninth oh did he
get a breaking ball right there that had
hit me all over it
it was i mean it did hardly anything
except go right into devil's
power matt barnes with the 02 to garver
high fly ball this one into left that
should do it verdugo backing up a bit
and the red sox have made it seven in a
row
they come to minnesota and knock off the
twins 4-2